c'est patrick r non non je me suis coupé
le doigt avant de venir commente été
coupée le douar et j'ai voulu remettre
une appli qui était pas droite françois
et ensemble un teint hâlé plus en prison
vous repasser par la case départ et vous
toucherez sans se rendre compte 5
millions d'euros partent en est où
justement il s'était à faire des 135
millions là aujourd'hui je viens
d'apprendre que la cour de cassation qui
devait se prononcer en juillet début
juillet
le premier président a fait un
communiqué pour dire que c'était
reporter en séance plénière au début
octobre
donc ça veut dire tu as gagné en
première instance a gagné en appel l'ag
en cassation si en cassation tu gagnes
tu as gagné tu récupères le pognon et si
tu perds serre jugés entièrement depuis
le début non non c'est la sarre pas au
moins une chambre d'appel alors on
appelle à on revient à l'appel ouais
mais ça fera là donc je ça va faire
trois mois de plus donc ça fera 12 ans
et 6 mois que c'est les jours sans faim
c'est sans fin 12 ans et sim dans la
sortie c 135 ans c'est trop dur et je
vais pas me mettre dans la poche rien
toi très gras dans dans les poches de
l'état